ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen microsoft
hält meine lieben freunde bevor
irgendetwas passiert in der heutigen
episode möchte ich erstmal etwas machen
was in letzter zeit ein bisschen zu kurz
kam
eine schweige sekunde für unsere
verstorbene kuh und die verstorbene
katze jetzt müssen wir allerdings direkt
an die arbeit gehen denn wir wurden die
kommentare geschrieben luca macht die
unbedingt eine diamant rüstung was ist
denn hier wieder für eine party ich will
nicht mit dir handeln ich habe gar keine
zeit verhandeln denn ich nehme eine
diamanten und mache mir jetzt mal
endlich eine volle diamant rüstung dass
die auch langsam echt nötig denn ich bin
die so oft gestorben weil ich diese
dumme reise rüstung die ganze zeit noch
an hat und jetzt haben wir endlich genug
diamanten die ich ja abgebaut habe
entdeckt mich mit diamanten
ich bin ich flexibler aber ich bin schon
reichlich und hässlich oder so einen
dummen popel hängers wie die ob wir
müssen allerdings uns noch eine schere
machen für heute sagt und was ich auch
noch brauche ist meine spitzhacke mit
der behutsamkeit sind denn was denn ich
werde jetzt erstmal ganz kurz ein
bisschen weizen abbauen das benötigen
wir nämlich um unsere kühe da unten so
ein bisschen wieder vermehren zu können
damit wir müssen die irgendwann töten
damit wir da bekommen und sei eigentlich
ist hier für die heutige episode ist es
nicht dass wir die tür töten und
dementsprechend endlich mal ein bisschen
leder bekommen sondern stets bereits mit
titel
ich weiß nicht ob das klappen wird aber
ich will mir einen see bauen und diesen
sehen möchte ich am liebsten genau dort
hin bauen wo gerade unsere farm ist
deswegen werde ich die wahrscheinlich
abreißen müssen im heutigen video
allerdings habe ich mir vorgenommen
demnächst ein paar einzelne inseln noch
neben unsere standard insel zu bauen das
hat mich auch unten die kommentare
geschrieben dann ist unsere insel
nämlich erstens nichts zufolge baut ich
kann mich bei uns mehr darauf
konzentrieren dass alles irgendwie schön
aussieht und so was wie beispielsweise
weizen
modersohn trams kann ich dann eben
wieder neben hinbauen ihr seht auch
schon nicht gerade wieder ein paar
franken ab die benötige ich nämlich für
den seen und da möchte ich nämlich ein
bisschen bemooste steine hin machen und
so weiter und so fort
und ich werde auch schon ich befinde
mich gerade gefährlich nah an diesen
bergen hier das hat nämlich auch einen
grund denn ich werde nun noch mal kurz
in die höhe gehen
wir liegen auch noch steine von uns sie
können auch noch mit dem davon wollen
nämlich auch eine menge denn ein anderes
ziel was wir haben ist ja immer noch
unser bahnstrecken wir haben wir viel zu
viele ziele in diesem projekt allerdings
schaue jetzt erst mal was wir unten
letztes noch nicht mitnehmen konnten die
ganzen kohleblöcke hier nehmen nicht die
kann ich allerdings das wollten wir auch
unten die kommentare geschrieben einfach
mal zu solchen blöcken machen dann sind
die nämlich nicht so viel platz
wegnehmen inventar mein ziel
das ist sich war die gal das ist doch
das kann doch nicht wahr sein dass räder
einfach ankommt durch dass sich meine
map hier ausgedacht hat
da habe ich übrigens auch 12 negative
kommentare gelesen unter der letzten
hüllen folgen wo ich ganz kurz mal drauf
eingehen wollte und zwar wurde mir da
geschrieben
luca das was mir gerade mal auffällt
bisher nämlich doch hier im schnee
region gebiet links oder das heißt
eigentlich müssten jedoch irgendwo
fichtenholz bäume sein damit ich nicht
immer in unser dummes dummes iranische
fahnen muss aber hier sind überhaupt
keine
ich habe auf jeden fall unter den höhlen
folge vorgestern leider einige
kommentare von besserwissern lesen
müssen die meisten leute lasst euch
nicht verarschen luca platziert die
ganzen diamant ärzte vorher schon gerade
deswegen ist dieses projekt so
interessant weil die map ist gar nicht
so krass aber der macht das alles oft
kamera und blabla und das stimmt einfach
nicht
also wenn solche durch das glauben
wollen okay aber wenn ich euch
irgendwann den zieht gebe könnt ihr
gerne zu jedem einzelnen diamant ärztin
laufen und sehen dass ich hier nichts
auf kämmerer machen was geht ab alter
schwede
du hast auf mich abzuschießen weg
das ist nicht wahr ich muss ich muss
ganz schnell weg gegangen
ich muss ganz schnell weg ich hoffe ich
habe vier ganzen pack
ich habe keine ahnung wo ich hier jetzt
wieder rein geraten bin werde dennoch
den schleim hier vorne jetzt mal
angreifen und versuchen zu töten denn
dass ich jetzt immer schon ganz geil
wenn wir das ding hier vorne kam
allerdings glätte noch angelaufen
per sowie zunächst erstmal zu töten sagt
hier an der seite
nicht getroffen oder nicht getroffen
jetzt
ich bin keine fahrt nutzen
ich wollte einfach nur kurz in die höhe
gehen und die restlichen sachen holen
natürlich ist sie wieder komplett chaos
ich gehe jetzt einfach mal hier kurz
runter unter wasser mit meiner gold
spitzhacke auf der behutsamkeit drauf
ist und damit können wir uns jetzt
nämlich hier so ein paar korallen
blätter mitnehmen die ich auf jeden fall
bei mir in den kleinen serien packen
wollte weil das glaube ich ganz schön
aussieht das zuckerrohr was sich hinten
an der höhle abgebaut habe packe ich
jetzt erst mal hier und unsere farm rein
wir sehen schon das ist ja auch schon
deutlich weiter gewachsen allerdings
wird das hier auch gleich alles weg
gemacht und jetzt wahrscheinlich warum
wird das hier weg gemacht
wartet mal wenn er dieser folge jetzt
richtig richtig geil aussehen ein
perspektivisches ziel ist es auf jeden
fall unsere insel auf der wir uns gerade
befinden und auf der wir leben so schön
zu machen wie es irgendwie geht
allerdings die produktivität hinten
reinzustellen also beispielsweise so
sachen die wir brauchen in die richtung
essen oder zucker ort zum verzaubern für
bücher und so weiter und so fort so was
möchte ich lieber outsourcen auf
irgendwelche anderen inseln dann
beispielsweise hier vorne eine kleine
tier insel hier vorne dann gingen die
schildkröten
den später ich habe nur so ein paar item
sortiert und direkt schild da wieder so
ein penner und weg mit dir und weg mit
dir und mir sagen warum machst du denn
eigentlich nichts ist gut so wir haben
alles am start und ihr seht auch schon
dass ich hier so einen kleinen umriss
schon mal angefertigt habe hier können
wir jetzt ganz einfach noch eine ebene
tiefer gehen allerdings am rand einen
blog freilassen zu dem rand von unserem
see zack zack zack hier vorne herum
ich brauche hier geraten sie also bitte
geht
danke schön also hier an den seiten auf
jeden fall ein blogger freilassen hier
das in der mitte auch noch eben abtragen
und dann müssen wir auch noch mal eine
ebene tiefer gehenden der see soll er
nicht nur zweiter sein sondern du
solltest du wohnst seit sechs monaten in
hamburg
also halt dein maul jetzt sieht das
ganze hier auf jeden fall schon mal so
aus ich habe es auch gerade noch so ein
bisschen erweiterte nach links hin weil
wir jetzt hier auch ein bisschen mehr
platz haben wenn die farm weg ist jetzt
müssen wir einfach hier so ein paar
blöcke ersetzen zum beispiel hier kommt
dann irgendwie einem oster bruchstein
hin dann kommt hier vorne wieder ein
normaler bruchsteine hin dass wäre ich
jetzt auch einfach mal ganz kurz machen
[Musik]
so sieht es jetzt aus da könnt ihr
wirklich komplett willkürlich vorgehen
an den rand werde ich jetzt auch noch so
ein paar stufen hier hinsetzen also mal
bemoost mal nicht bewusst hier vorne
irgendwie hier um die ecke hier
vielleicht auch nur zweite dann eben
hier dann auch noch mal so eine jeder
wieder eine bewusste die anleitung das
werden die ganzen minecraft sucht die
schon kennen ist wieder von selb xl
finde ich mega mega show die den see
gebaut hat deswegen orientiere ich mich
da so ein bisschen dran aber der kann ja
jeder vorgehen wie er möchte
so sieht das hier vorne jetzt raus und
diese bruchstein stufen können wir jetzt
auch hier runter noch weiter durchsetzen
also ihr merkt schon
man kann da wirklich bauen wie man will
der kreativität sind hier keine grenzen
gesetzt ist er ein ganz bekannter spruch
von mir ich nehme jetzt allerdings meine
bruchstein treppen und die bemoosten
bruchstein treppen und werde die hier
auch noch so ein bisschen rum platzieren
sie das nämlich auch ganz schön aus
also einfach wirklich alles kreuz und
quer setzen damit das hier so ein
bisschen verbucht hat aussieht ein
bisschen famos und so und jetzt nehmen
wir unsere erde und bauen das hier als
geht ja jetzt
machen abmarsch egal dann bleibt er auf
jeden fall hier drin
[Musik]
du willst mich komplett verarschen oder
volk gerade gehen
[Musik]
sag mir bitte noch einer dass sich diese
mobster selber hin setze ich habe gerade
mit mir selber im schnitt geredet damit
ich weiß was ich später über das schaf
schreibe und was das schaf mir halt sagt
und dann klickst genau in dem moment
ihren creeper alt ich weiß gar nicht wie
das jetzt alles gebaut hat hab das jetzt
einfach irgendwie wieder hingesetzt und
werde jetzt meine erde neben einer diese
schafe wenn ich das schon sehr das ist
ein gutes omen für meine skills hier in
minecraft die aber leider auch nicht
vorhanden sind da ich jetzt alles
zugebaut habe kann ich nun ganz easy am
rand einfach wassereimer setzen und das
wasser ergänzt sich bis zum ende des
sees in die ecken von alleine wenn ich
da ziemlich offen gelassen hätten wir
das mit dem schildkröten
ich könnte bei den schildkröten da vorne
weil gucken das neunte der
wahrscheinlich sind unsere eier
geschnürt und hier geht nichts voran da
hier vorne jetzt das wasser komplett auf
einer fläche ist kann ich die er
pflückte hier ist auch wieder wegnehmen
es geht die sonne tatsächlich schon
wieder unterricht bei der raw aufnahmen
bei fast zwei stunden da ist jetzt
allerdings gerade schon wieder dunkel
wird können wir die chance und die gunst
der stunde jetzt einfach mal nutzen und
unsere mädels gucken her tschammer darin
platz
wir beleuchten die nicht
leuchten die meeres gurken nicht
leuchten meinem jetzigen nicht hier
leuchten die aber warum nicht wenn ich
die hier vorne bei mir rein stelle
deshalb exakt st
ich möchte dich
ich glaube der erkennt irgendwie nicht
dass ihr wasser und ich musste immer was
da noch mal drauf machen die vorne setzt
sich dann auf jeden fall auch noch
meeres guten hin und vielleicht hier
auch noch dann haben jetzt hier auch
noch ein bisschen beleuchtet sagt diesen
direkt beleuchtet also soll das dann auf
jeden fall aussehen so dass es auch in
der dunkelheit so ein bisschen schön süß
aussieht die meeres gucken können wir an
der stelle dann ging's direkt wieder
zurück packen zusammen mit den
wassereimer was wir als nächstes
brauchen sind die rosenblätter wehten
seegras und jetzt geht so ein bisschen
ans eingemachte
hier kommt jetzt nämlich alles ein
bisschen zum leben und zwar platziere
ich einfach random irgendwo so ein
bisschen seegras sakhir fordere hier an
den ecken hier bamm bamm bamm und dann
hier auch ein bisschen seetang der so
ein bisschen höher wächst sieht glaube
ich auch ganz süß aus und natürlich
nicht nur im see drin soll verbucht
aussehen sondern auch auf dem sie drauf
deswegen habe ich ja die seerosenblätter
von so ein bisschen mitgenommen da
können wir hier einfach mal random
einzupacken
hier vorne hier rüber kommt auch noch
eins hier vorne und sack und dann habe
ich auch noch die fichtenholz falschen
gerade in der hand da fragt er jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch luca war selbst mit
den machen ich möchte hier zum beispiel
sonne korallen platte krams kacke drauf
bauen dann hier vorne irgendwo um die
ecke wo kann man es noch machen hier
vielleicht irgendwie bam bam hier drauf
dann so ein blaues und das letzte
seerosen blatt bz weg ein seerosen blatt
sondern korallenriff krams booms ist ich
mein minecraft ist perfekt das letzte
platziere ich jetzt einfach mal hier
vorne dann haben wir das hier oben an
der oberfläche auch so ein bisschen
schön was wir nun allerdings glaube ich
nur noch brauchen sind die
bruchsteinmauern und die laternen denn
es soll natürlich auch ein bisschen
beleuchtet sein es ist jetzt natürlich
gerade taghell aber ich glaube so wollte
ich das nicht hier vorne noch eine
bruchsteinmauer hin mit einer laterne
dann einmal hier um den baum herum
gelaufen dann können wir hier
beispielsweise noch keine hin packen
hier vorne auch noch eben kurz und die
letzte dann vielleicht irgendwie hier
kommt noch eine was soll der geiz dann
kommt hier vorne irgendwie auch noch
eine hin
ich habe dass sie extra freigelassen
weil und da müssen jetzt einmal ganz
kurz nach unten gehen ich jetzt
tatsächlich den kompletten zuckerrohr
bestand dem wir haben
und es geht denn hier ab der garten sind
creepers bitte um in gott dinge auf
einmal wieder völlig im fight ihr weg
mit euch noch ein letzter zack jetzt
immer hier rein zu den skeletten einer
kammer zombies raus ich muss auf jeden
fall die komplette höhle gleich mal zu
bauen
alter und die kommen noch mehr rauskommt
alter schwede was geht denn da
abgekommen und skelette rau hat das geht
denn ab da unten schnitt auch noch und
wie bei da kommt wieder an
der körper ist oder ich muss das direkt
alles zubauen vorne wobei der hier unten
schild der kripo
jetzt hier noch das skelett alter wo
kommen die alle her
jetzt mal einfach meinen bruchstein und
baue hier die höhle erstmal zu weil die
kommen ja logischerweise alle da unten
raus ich bin allerdings hier weil ich
jetzt gerade das zucker woche erst mal
mitnehmen wollte denn soviel zuckerrohr
wie ich mir hier angepflanzt haben bzw
so viel sand wie hier hingesetzt habe
sind hier brauche ich eigentlich gar
nicht und deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
und dafür soll das projekt auch so ein
bisschen stehen und das ist ja auch
meine ansicht lieber ein bisschen länger
und ein paar folgen mehr dann irgendwie
auf ein bisschen zucker erwarten aber
dafür ist alles schön und gefühl und zu
hause und das ist jetzt auch das was ich
euch zu beginn noch nicht sagen wollte
denn ich mache hier und da vorne noch
mal das weg was sich da hingebaut habe
denn ich möchte einen fluss durch unsere
minecraft welt laufen lassen dafür bauen
wir hier unseren kleinen trampelpfad
einfach mal damit müssen wir natürlich
auch eine kleine brücke darüber bauen
also wirklich eine minimale butter und
hier das kommt dann auch erstmal auch
mal weg und dieser art blog auch und
hier der kommission auch die treppe
nämlich auch mal ganz kurz mit wir bauen
das gleich noch ein bisschen schöner
allerdings erst mal zu zeigen wurde
fritz lang laufen soll einmal hier in
die richtung dann sollst hier quasi
runtergehen er soll hier unten münden
alles hier wird an den seiten ein
bisschen zugebaut mit zuckerrohr so dass
wir da auf jeden fall uns einige papiere
machen können und hier vorne auf der
anderen seite soll es auch ins wasser
münden und zwar hier vorne geht bei euch
dann den weg auch mal eben die insel
reparatur folge muss echt irgendwann mal
kommen den sie können den später
egal was sind das verstauen
ich habe keine ahnung warum die
plötzlich wieder bei mir sind das
verkaufte mit den tropen baumsetzlinge
ich glaube es hat sich noch nie jemand
so krasse über einen fichtenholz
setzling gefreut wie ich aber ich
brauche den wirklich weil ich
fichtenholz so schön finden in minecraft
deswegen werde ich jetzt einfach
wirklich fünf märkte ausgeben um jetzt
und fichten setzling zu holen damit wir
den wasser zu denen du stinkst ich
glaube ich selbst die fichte einfach mal
hier mitten aus wasser war aus prinzip
weil wir so lange fichte mit gesucht
haben sogar noch zu beginn in dieser
folge habe ich mir gedacht hey ich bin
also im schnitt keine ahnung berge wie
jung da müsst euch im westen seiner bahn
kann aber jetzt hier maultier vorne
mündet er dann runter direkt im wasser
und hier an die seiten da kommen jetzt
mal unser zucker wahrnehmen können wir
dann auf jeden fall alles voll pflanzen
und uns ein bisschen das sogar was wir
halt brauchen für unsere bücher etc auf
eine vernünftige art und weise holen und
jetzt nicht irgendwie unter jede straße
farm bauen und blabla sondern so dass es
hier also ein bisschen schöner aussieht
und hier vorne auch noch und hier vorne
auftakt dann sieht's aus der entfernung
halt so aus als wenn das hier ein ganz
normaler wasserfall ist also einfluss
der irgendwie hier untergeht und dann
mündet und hier vorne sieht es auch ganz
schön aus und es geht dann so ein
bisschen einher mit unserem sie hier
vorne könnte ich jetzt einfach weil ich
weiß nicht ob ich die gerade hier habe
ich glaube aber die sind oben genau
meine holz stein holz hier finde mich
jetzt mal unsere eichenholz stufen und
packte hier so ein bisschen drüber dann
haben wir mich hier so eine ganz kleine
minimale brücke mit der wir hier über
laufen können und das ganze sich ein
bisschen schöner ausgemacht dass man so
zac und dann können wir den weg auch
noch hier so ein bisschen andeuten dir
vorne geht es dann weiter hoch hier
vorne habe ich auch gerade noch so ein
paar bruchstein stufen hingesetzt und
jetzt machen wir noch mal eben schnell
fix dass hier auf der anderen seite
fertig jetzt muss ich eigentlich auch
nur noch diesen stein da oben abbauen
und dann fließt es auch schon runter
zack und jetzt sehen wir es funktioniert
auf jeden fall alles fließt darunter in
unser wasser
dass ich doch eigentlich schon direkt
ganz schönes also ich würde sogar
vielleicht direkt zu lassen könnt mir
gern runden die kommentare schreiben ob
ich ihr noch irgendwas anders bauen
sollte ihr das ganze sieht und hier um
den see herum setzt sich jetzt natürlich
auch ein bisschen zuckerrohr weil ich
das eigentlich auch ganz schön finde
dann haben wir halt unsere kleine
zuckerrohr farm und nicht mehr
allerdings hier jetzt so ein bisschen
immer die möglichkeit wenn wir
zuckerrohr brauchen hier einfach
irgendwas abzubauen und das ist glaube
ich ein bisschen schöner dass sie auf
unserer insel ein bisschen schöner aus
hier den bau mit euch noch ein bisschen
dass ich auch ein bisschen besser aus
und was wir machen müssen und deswegen
habe ich ja extra am ende der letzten
folge danke da übrigens für euer riesig
krankes feedback zu der episode weil wir
da er wieder richtig viele sachen
mitgenommen hatten aus der höhe und
unter anderem ja auch eine menge knochen
das habe ich ganz einfach gemacht damit
ich mir das knochenmehl holt was sind
[ __ ] ich werde hier jetzt mal alles
voll bauen mit bäumen denn das fehlt so
ein bisschen irgendwie und ich finde
bäume machen minecraft immer noch so ein
bisschen schöner da kommt natürlich
direkt vom baum hier der dächer diese
dummen lamas da oben der bei mir wird
aber immer direkt wieder weg gemacht
sagt kommen ein kraft gibt mir eine neue
chance von etwas größeren baum so der
ist auf jeden fall sehr schön geworden
dann kann mir beispielsweise vorne neben
das grab von noch einen nebensätzen hier
zack zack zack
das wird ein ganz großer baum
rausgewachsen auch ganz geil aus hier
vorne setzte ich noch einen hin bam bam
der ist mir ein bisschen blöder geworden
jetzt werde ich allerdings auch dass
knochen mir nehmen und hier auf dem
boden war so ein bisschen was verteilen
damit alles so ein bisschen verbucht und
verwachsen aussieht hier kann ich auch
noch so ein kleines bäumchen hinsetzen
ich hoffe er wird jetzt nicht allzu
riesig nie geht auf jeden fall auch klar
hier vorne neben machen wir auch noch so
ein bisschen knochen bildern sieht auch
ein bisschen schöner aus und hier und
hier kann auch noch ein kleiner baum hin
findig bamm bamm bamm so hier kann auch
noch einen baum hin wir haben echt noch
einige setzlinge also fünf stück hummer
loch ich bin jetzt mal noch ein bisschen
knochenmehl vorne drauf damit alles halt
einfach ein bisschen verruchte aussieht
hier vorne können und zum beispiel auch
noch einen baum hinsetzen
[Musik]
es gibt denn die übersicht
ich war gemacht ich mache noch mal eben
die restlichen knochen die ich habe zu
knochenmehl und werde hier vorne
versuchen noch einen geilen baum
rauskriegen hier vorne beim ok der ist
auf jeden fall ganz schön geworden und
hier vorne auf dem boden drauf und hier
hinten habe ich auch gerade gedacht hier
kann man auch noch ein bisschen was hin
verteilen
hier so ein bisschen an die ecken und
hier vorne wo das ding rhein mündet
könnte so ein baum vielleicht auch ganz
schön aussehen nämlich genau hier und
dann sieht es hier so ein bisschen aus
als wird der bach so durch den kleinen
wald hier durchgehend dass sie macht es
natürlich nicht so viel sinn
das können wir so kurz dribbeln es ist
schon schön
ich bin richtig happy hier vorne die
fichte können wir auch mal direkt
wachsen lassen ich habe jetzt noch ein
bisschen knochenmehl immer direkt mal
hin zack zack zack zack zack da haben
wir die fichte und damit können wir dann
weiter unsere fichtenholz farmen bauen
hier soll dann generell noch mal
sonnenwald auf den aufs meer
dann kommt hier die tiere insel hin dann
kommt die farm insel irgendwo hin also
es wird richtig richtig geil leute wenn
ihr noch kein teil von meinem kanalseite
und kein teil von diesem projekt ihr
seid anlass gerne einen daumen hoch und
ein video hier dauernd abonniert main
kanal damit den neue videos nicht
verpassen werdet meine lieben freunde
morgen kommt ein neues video online
heute war es ja auch wieder eine kleine
xxl folge die nächstes nächste video
wird er noch jeden fall ein bisschen
kürzer
ich muss jetzt erst mal chillen das ist
wieder mitten in der nacht und wir sehen
uns wieder
[Musik]